good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday i am
just floored i'm humbled i'm feeling
disrespected
because miss shannon ford is in the
building and she had the absolute goal
you know i shouldn't put my [ __ ] on you
like i decided to look like crap today
and i knew you were coming and i should
have just known better you know
i thought about it and i really i said
you know should i do a little dress down
moment a little athleisure and then i
thought absolutely [ __ ] not i'm not
doing that i'm like embarrassed to take
a photo with you we always take a photo
after to like promote and honestly i'm
embarrassed it's like when you show up
to see the queen you gotta just oh [ __ ]
we have gotten so many requests for you
to come on the toast
and to be honest we hadn't even met
until literally last week yes and it was
just love at first sight i agree like
i'm obsessed with you you're so pretty
and funny like i die i had the most fun
last weekend too i feel like it was the
best atmosphere to meet for the first
time 100 percent our way through the
whole night
for the morning we painted the town i
don't even know like so many colors so
many colors so many colors too many
colors you are in new york early now a
lot of people know you of course from
your time on reality tv which i want to
get into just because that like sounds
like the worst thing ever
um i don't think i could ever be on atv
i'm far too insecure um and now you're
just like influencing podcasting taking
over the world you just got a place in
new york i did it's um a lot to learn
like i remember putting it i put in the
gps to get here i was like she's an
upper east side girly pop
soho i'm gonna make sure that we are on
time and i was still like profusely
sweating through this
beast of an outfit because i was like
gave myself 45 minutes to get here but
i'm just still not sure if we're on time
so learning a lot um i have like a
bodega that's like right downstairs and
i'm trying to be all like new york and i
keep like waiting for them to remember
who i am and like my order and they're
just like what do you want and i'm like
yeah it doesn't work like that it takes
years like actual years truly truly yeah
and they always i can see them silently
judging me whenever i get mayonnaise on
my sandwich they're like oh yes what is
your what is your go-to bodega order i
just get a sausage egg and cheese and
also they're like rolling with mayo yeah
i don't eat sausage egg and cheese but i
know like a lot of people do and i've
never heard of anyone putting mayo i
know nobody does really people i put
mayo in like everything
i'm a mayo girl this friendship was
going places i know but we've we're at a
halt a lot of people share that same
sentiment and it's upsetting but i just
i'm a male girly through and through i'm
a press on nelly girl
the episode with hannah burner yeah we
all have our things we all have our
vices ben is a mayo girly as well oh
okay yeah that's a good condiment what
is your opinion on like light mayo
because ben has like a full dissertation
written on it yeah for me personally i'm
immediately out yeah nothing to do with
it i don't know why it's a thing it's
just absolutely appalling and i don't
think it should be on the shelves i
think the fda really [ __ ] up with
approving that one i completely agree me
and ben over the weekend i just came
back from texas and ben got a burger and
he wanted it was an impossible burger
and ben wanted mayo and they brought him
vegan mayo
not interested and he was like really
upset yeah immediately out immediately
you're doing the things you need to do
by getting an impossible burger give us
the give us the real name right and you
know i've actually oh
that's why they brought him vegan mayo
because it was an impossible yeah we'll
probably
oh think about that either though i'm
like he's trying to be good he's eating
an impossible burger give him the real
stuff oh my god no that makes sense it's
actually extremely considerate it's
really nice actually oh my god that's so
nice i didn't even think of that i'm
chuck um okay so you're so now you're
like between nashville and new york yeah
i spend time in both it's just you know
i was coming here so often you this
summer whenever i was at the spritz yes
oh that's where we first met actually
yeah true through hang on
and i didn't know anyone there and i
didn't want to be like the girl
following the hosts around so i was just
like hi and then i was like literally so
[ __ ] lonely and oh my god i'm so
sorry no it's no one's responsibility
but i was like you know like i go into
these events and i'm like first of all i
am like extroverted i'm gonna talk to
people and then i was like sitting next
to the bartender like so how long have
you guys been here
you gotta go but also that was the time
where i wore that outfit stunning thank
you but it was like a very you they sent
a dress code out beforehand that was
like i talked about this on my podcast i
guess new yorkers like don't give a [ __ ]
about a dress code really no and so the
dress code was like cute little like
fruit emojis for spring colors yeah like
bright colors and i was like not a
problem and i dressed like a [ __ ]
girl you nailed it and i think everyone
thought i worked there one girl did ask
me where the bathroom was and i don't
know if it's because she thought i'd
gone or if she said i worked there but i
felt like i should be holding a tray
passing stuff out because everyone was
in like navy blues and blacks you know
what's so funny that that's your
experience from the spritz party because
how i perceived it you're like really
intimidating like you're so tall you
have this presence about you you're
literally like a supermodel so i my my
impression of you was like oh she's like
too cool like let me just be nice like i
want to be your friend so like that
that's funny that's what your perception
was because you didn't give that off i
was like she is just like too cool for
us i met remy that day too like we were
sitting in line at the elevator together
and so um no i i still i feel like
people reached out to me afterwards on
instagram we're like oh i saw you at the
party so i made friends and connections
from that party which is really nice
that is nice yeah for the most part the
bartenders were like we have work to do
here and we can't talk to you and i was
like what is this that you're mixing
with the tequila what i love
that is fun
and they were like
go away
you're also a podcaster now you've had
like a lot of podcast drama i mean
jackie were like really invested yes
right oh yeah can you tell me like what
happened with your podcast yeah so
it was like one of those moments where
it's almost like you know how there's
people who have podcast drama like
obviously like an iconic one the caller
daddy so that was like dramatic as [ __ ]
and they don't talk anymore and like
whatever right mine was
harder because it was it's my actual
like really dear strain i was just in
florida with her and she was like
completely taking like a shift on her
life and just like woke up one day and
like truly purely was like i don't think
this aligns with what i want to do
anything right and moved to florida with
my husband and i was like
what are you gonna tell your best friend
like when she's doing the best thing for
her for her and you know that and that's
what she wants to do i was just like
oh
okay like i was just like okay what do
you want to do i'm going to lose my
podcast and my best friend or i just
won't lose the podcast right then i you
know i was like i'll just rebrand and
then my four-year relationship um i
ended that like within the same like
month and a half period so then i was
like you know
i'm gonna take a little break from just
talking i don't think i should be
talking to anyone right now like on on
the interwebs i think i should just lay
the [ __ ] alone for a bit and kind of
like process these like honestly losses
of course
that it was less drama it was more just
like it was [ __ ] sad yeah it was just
a big bummer and we you know like i
don't even know how this happened but we
like charted really like number one the
podcast was killing it it was crushing
it and we were just had so much momentum
and i was so excited and then i was just
like you know as high as you are it's
like the further the fall right like
okay well and then you go through that
perfectionism where you're like i can't
restart because what if it's not as good
as the other one and then you have
people being like just start and that's
anything in life you just need to start
it especially with a podcast like you
talk about it you can whatever just you
don't need a business plan just starting
yeah it'll come afterwards yeah so
anyways that's the it wasn't as much and
now it's so great it's been so it feels
like it's been so long and you and your
friend are still good we're i was just
at her house for four days really that's
why i just wasn't you love to see female
friendships getting through tough times
yeah and not like i said if any friend
in life is like doing something to
better themselves who the [ __ ] are you
to not do that that doesn't make you a
real friend anymore and like if you get
mad at it then like you're the toxic one
you're toxic yeah so meat not toxic
friend
do you think you're toxic um am i the
drama
am i the
villain
um i think i could have probably a
couple toxic traits but i recognize them
and i'm like oh you're doing that thing
yeah is it toxic if you recognize it
because i don't think so i don't think
so personally but that's probably just
me saying that for myself that's you
being toxic that's me being toxic that's
one of my toxic traits yeah i think my
toxic trait which you've probably
already realized is i talk over everyone
i do that too um and so i just want to
apologize in advance i'll also apologize
in advance but i probably won't because
i'm a little scared of you and being on
the set so i probably won't talk over
you but like i do that on my podcast and
i have to like literally [ __ ] stop it
yeah it's hard yeah it's tough it is
especially when i get into a groove with
jackie like we we do a dance it's like
us speaking it's like we know when to
exit flows i know when to stop y'all are
perfect at it though and then like when
she's gone and i'm here meeting new
people which i love and it's great for
the podcast it's different i literally
don't know how to talk
it's bad i had to like issue a formal
apology like a formal apology on my
podcast after i had like a guest this
guy and like like every review every
single one of them and here's the thing
like i was editing the podcast at the
time so they don't even realize i cut
out how much
i cut out more times i interrupted him
actually like i interrupted him more but
i was cutting it out so whenever your
view was like you cannot stop
interrupting him i was like
well i don't think they're all just
saying this to be rude no that's the
actual helpful feedback yeah it is so
anyways that was that's that on that i
don't think i'm that toxic do you read a
lot of podcast reviews because you
should stop i don't i i really do just
forget about them i read i'm on
instagram so i read and no one's on
instagram posting this was the worst
podcast ever right people are saying
that nice and fair right yeah so i don't
i always forget that you can go to itu
because it takes a bit you have to go to
itunes you have to click on your podcast
you can see more yeah so i actually for
luckily i forget about that kind of me
too it's like the one place i don't
check because i always forget that they
exist and i'm glad about that because
yeah yeah i read it obviously hates me
and yeah everybody knows everybody
though why do people like i know why
people hate me but why would people hate
you um i think it's pretty easy uh i
just have to preface i didn't watch very
cavalier jackie did no no if it's from
that i don't know very capillary is it's
it's very rare people are still
disliking me from that that was like a
really like a long time ago for one
season and yeah no but now i think
people probably just dislike me because
i'm like really over the top really
talkative i do like the m i do the most
you do the mom
all the time and some people just don't
like people that do the most and some
people are like
do the most yes
i don't know i
my entire life i've just literally
always been you either like me or you
just cannot [ __ ] stand me and my
whole life i was so fixated on like
getting everyone like me like i mean my
mom would have to sit me down and be
like my girl right it's just not gonna
happen and i i feel very happy that i've
passed that point in my life where i try
to make everyone laugh and i can tell
pretty quickly i'm like oh oil and water
we don't really mesh but yeah and
sometimes it sucks because i'll really
like the other person right now but you
know that's life and it is what it is so
in the words of danielle staub you're
either going to love me or hate me there
is no individual in between and i'm very
much i find that a lot of people who
like work in this space have that i'm
very similar like all i want in this
world is to be universally beloved and
for anyone that's not a thing especially
if you're like in a podcaster like
you're always going to be
dividing divided and i'm like a
polarizing person i always have
polarizing like hot takes on things and
so like yeah as do you and so i just it
would be
ignorant to think that everyone is going
to be like i just love that little girly
pop yeah
you know and you know what else is so
interesting to me about you like just
having followed your
the arc of your career since the show i
think a lot of people who have been in a
similar space have as you have
kind of become that girl from that show
and i think that in the years since you
left the show like i don't even remember
that you were on that show like you've
done such a good job of like creating
space for yourself on the internet with
your podcast with your instagram just
all your content and i think that that's
so hard so i really commend you for that
thank you no i mean i was also like i i
don't want to say that the whole show
was edited like i was saying and doing
this thing right i was totally playing a
character and like yes of course kristin
honestly was really like nice and
guiding me through the whole process and
she was like you know we need someone
polarizing we need kind of a villain and
i was like i'm volunteer tribute right
because i was like if i'm gonna st stoop
this is five years ago not that like
like if you're doing reality tv you were
like
right it wasn't like yeah i wasn't like
yeah i can't wait to see your season it
was like you're going on a reality tv
show yeah and so i was like if i'm gonna
do this trash [ __ ] then i'm gonna
[ __ ] do it
yeah like honestly yeah i panned out so
yeah it's not yeah you gotta be
polarizing you couldn't be here without
that totally and people are always like
yeah i talk [ __ ] about i'm like no i
don't i'm like very understanding that
that was my giant platform right but i
also am who i am and i don't like i
guess i didn't create a character and
then just stick in that character yeah
this is actually me and i'm doing the
work now so now that i like know you i
really want to go back and watch the
show just because tragic and my teeth
were so long
like crying my teeth were trending on
twitter after the show
it was very do you have new teeth now um
so i had him shave him down this is
actually i leave tomorrow and go to
houston to get new teeth oh my god i
just got back from houston yesterday oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah georgetown gorgeous
gorgeous town gorgeous gorgeous girls
girly gorgeous new teeth in houston love
that for you good good luck yeah they're
going to crack them off the ones i have
now with like a pecan cracker so just
like let that marinate for a second
because i so you have veneers that's
right
veneers now that i don't love and so to
get these veneers off their porcelain
they get like a pecan cracker and crack
them off oh my god beauty is pain
that is just i'd like to put me out
they should
yeah you get numb but i asked for some
laughing gas and she was like yeah we're
gonna do that right well because then
like you're awake but until you hear all
the sounds the sound and the pressure
and the like
my nipples are hard
well shannon is here to join me of
course to deliver the past five i
actually have six stories today just
because it's been a while since we did a
show because i was on tour thanks to
everyone who came out to the shows by
the way i'll be at chicago on friday and
kansas city on sunday and today is
tuesday and you normally do this on
monday but i did want to get your input
on unburden yourselves which is a
segment we do here on mondays from the
morning toast where people can just
write in you know have you ever had a
weekend where you know you were having
fun but something you did was so
embarrassing that it ruined like you
can't think about the weekend without
thinking about the time you fell in
front of mary kate olsen that's what
happened to me and that's what spiraled
this entire oh my god it might have been
ashley i'm not sure but that's what
started this segment it feels good to
just unburden yourself once you talk
about it you can really set it free do
you think that the guy that fell in the
pool at the spritz party like
that was him that was his that was his
yes that happened at the sports party so
we've all been there and it makes you
feel less alone so we have three
submissions from girlies who wrote in
we'll do that at the end of the show and
i do believe that you might unburden
yourself with something you did recently
let me think i was just uh in florida i
had this which in west we were in west
palm which is a beautiful town and i was
just it was very it was hot there it was
a humid place um this isn't like that
but when you brought this up before the
show i was like oh what was i like so i
gave myself the ich about
i just like kept i was in front of a lot
of important people and i kept like not
liking my hair so i went to the bathroom
and i would like put it in a put it in
like a clip cute with like little pieces
hanging front and i can't strands
someone was like oh i like your hair i
was like it's just so hot and then i
like went to the bathroom again i was
like i hate my hair and so i took it
down and i put two braids in the front
and i came back and i think i realized
by the end of the day when this like guy
was like
you just like have had like four
hairstyles since we've been here i just
realized i look like that girl that was
just like oh no no i mean like i was
inserting braids at some point like
that's just stupid that's a commitment
we should just you know take it easy
just have a little bit of frizzy hair
and i was embarrassed that someone
literally was like called out i've seen
you here you've had four hairstyles he
helped you out honestly that was
disrespectful of him that was rude as
[ __ ] i was rude as [ __ ] um okay well
thank you for sharing that i hope you
feel better lighter and you can move
forward with you know more positive and
louder styles more positive less hair
every everything we have to unburden
ourselves with we learn a lesson from we
do for me it was like stop wearing such
big shoes you know were you wearing big
shoes i was wearing chunky hoppers like
huge boots platform probably six inches
like and it was like three in the
morning and out like i didn't even trip
i don't know how i felt i just collapsed
literally oh this was whenever this is
when you actually fell in front of me or
in front of mary slash kate
ashley um yeah it was just so
embarrassing and i was with my i've told
the story a thousand times but i was
with my friend gabe and like
i was like did you see that and he was
walking right in front of me when i fell
he was like no so i was like okay maybe
it wasn't as bad and i like tricked
myself into and i came on the podcast i
talked all about it and i was like but
gabe didn't see so like gabe said it was
fine and then literally a week later
gabe was like no i saw i just didn't
want to feel really bad so now like
it honestly unburdening myself like
hasn't made it better but
now making it into a segment at least it
was worth something it was where
something was worth the content and also
now we're wearing
less sensible sensible shoes like i'm
married i don't need to be wearing like
crazy heels you know we were wearing
some some tall we all took our shoes off
when we were out where are we what was i
wearing i was wearing the shoes that i
wore with you when we went out
were the shoes i wore when i thought no
yep well you took them off and i like we
all did but that's the same space and
you're going to be the only girl taking
your shoes off margo did it first and i
was like you know what i love that i
would love to take these off yeah but
like if you're the only girl like
wearing your shoes it's like you're the
one who can't hang yeah so you never
want to be the only girl to take off
your shoes but margo really created a
safe space for us to do that i will
always be the girl to like go to the
buffet line first or something but i
will not be the girl to take my shoes
off first actually i'm more conscious of
food so i'll be like the last person
online for the buffet but i won't be
wearing shoes okay yeah we all have our
barefoot in the buffet we're barefoot
that'll be the name of my next book
barefoot at the buffet
um okay so i think it's time shannon are
you ready to dive in we have six stories
today just because it's been a while
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
excuse me all birds spring is around the
corner and the warmer weather is perfect
for exercising outdoors
so that's why all birds is perfect for
spring really perfect for year round but
it's the perfect shoe perfect time to
get outside and move whatever your speed
so their tree dasher 2 is the next
evolution of their all birds
best-selling running shoe they add
comfort to every run with lighter more
responsive foam extra grip and an
improved fit to keep you running and
nature winning they're made from their
roster of natural materials like merino
wool eucalyptus and sugar cane their
lighter and more responsive foam adds a
spring to every step they have extra
traction
grips for the pavement and they have a
sportier angular heel which shape which
switch softens the impact on your foot
if you i don't know if i have flat feet
but like i don't have like normal feet
and i find the albert to be extremely
comfortable obviously i don't you know
spend a lot of time running outside but
i spent a lot of time running through
airports and all birds are super
comfortable so if you want to check out
the tree dasher 2 their running shoe
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s dot-com today's episode
is also brought to you by jenny kane
jenny kane is doing home now you love
her cardigans you love her shoes she's
doing home now and they have some
stunning pieces like the brentwood
buckle chair which comes in ivory and
natural boogle the handcrafted accent
chair that everyone is obsessed with
it's perfect for your bedroom your
living room or den
it adds interest and effortless style to
any room jenny kane is just like that
girl like she is effortless dad like if
you don't like i'm not great at like
design but i feel like if i buy anything
from jenny kane home like it's good you
know i know jenny's stamp of
approval is on it they also have candles
and slippers which i already have at my
house her candles smell amazing her
slippers are everything of the sort and
it's just the perfect thing that you
need to make your home like kind of like
a california retreat her scents are
inspired by california
they're hand poured in los angeles they
have shearling and suede slippers they
are the ultimate indoor indulgence so
get 20 off all furniture and home decor
free shipping on furniture early product
access and much more with jenny kane
home membership at
jennykaine.commembership or you can just
go to jennycaine.com home to create the
space you'll never want to leave that's
j e n n i k a y n e dot com slash home
all right shannon are you ready for your
first fast buy i'm so ready so the first
thing we have to talk about is the
grammys
they were on on sunday i did get a
chance to watch them after my show and
they were cute i i did the recap by via
you yeah they were cute they were cute
obviously everyone was like i like got
very over all the like slop talk like so
quickly i know we were all just like
marinating in it and we were just like
so everyone was talking about the
grammys and i don't realize i didn't
realize the grammys came so soon after
the oscars i know and i just like to be
honest like i'm still living in the
oscars yeah well everyone is yeah so
like when that happened i was like i'll
look at the outfit yeah and you know
what i felt like there was like kind of
a lot of star power missing like you
know beyonce wasn't there taylor swift
wasn't there ariana grande wasn't there
i didn't feel like it was really
star-studded it just felt like a very
new age yes young which like those
photos honestly will like be iconic
later on yeah we'll be like oh my god
look at olivia rodrigo and she was so
young true but like
in the moment we're like where the [ __ ]
is taylor swift yeah i know and she was
nominated for album of the year and a
lot of people are quaking because it was
i thought it was going to be like olivia
rodrigo sweep she was nominated in the
big four categories yes new artist album
of the year song of the year record of
the year and she only won new artists of
the year she won two other grammys but
not in the big four categories and
people were like quaking over jean
batiste who i
cannot lie i had not heard of i now know
he's like the
um band leader for the stephen colbert
show okay and when i was watching his
performance me and ben were like this
guy is everything like he was giving the
most yeah
so was i extremely surprised yes but i
have to imagine that's how other people
felt when casey musgraves won now
everyone loves casey muskrave but some
of us have been on the train for four or
five years and like we knew but i'm sure
a lot of people were like who well you
know do you remember when that that um i
mean i know he's iconic but
beck oh yeah when he swept the grammys
everyone was like everyone that i know
was like who the [ __ ] is back right
right and then i remember roles reversed
whenever chris stapleton swept the
grammys i being from nashville no and
obsessed over chris stapleton but at the
time everyone's like who that that gets
great and i was like don't you dare
right chris staple dinner's iconic so
like but i guess it just begs the
question
what is album of the year is it about
the the music that reached the most
people because i think in that case it
would have been olivia rodrigo or billy
i had to
or would you know about it as well yes
and taylor swift billy eilish olivia
rodrigo like it was stacked yeah so what
is album of the year is it you know
songs that sold the most or according to
the recording academy was the best like
substantially i think it's i think the
recording academy they pick it like
based on their
style yeah yeah i was just um i'm
shocked i'm not gonna lie like really
shocked i think like happier than ever
is that the one that was nominated i
mean that album top to bottom
top to bottom and then olivia's like i
don't even have to go into like it top
to bottom like the new apple reveal like
i'm a i'm an evermore girl like taylor
swift has done so much in the last few
years people like crap their pants over
folklore i did too but like
i really believe not enough people are
crapping their pants forever more i had
this uh debate with my friend because i
like ever more better than you yes me
too so i just like resonate with some of
the songs more i just think they're just
like so so vibrant special i love them i
think a lot of people consider evermore
to be like an afterthought of folklore
but
quickly but i totally disagree it was
like songs that weren't good enough for
folklore but i think it's better i i
like it better and i but i will say like
and i am a taylor swift stan
stan but if we were like going to put
the the two albums i do think olivia's
was better than ever more yes i i agree
i mean personally like my toxic trait is
just like blindly following taylor into
like off a bridge like i will do
anything into the abyss um but yes i
agree and i loved sour like i listened
to it back and forth all summer so for
me it was like kind of a no-brainer that
she was gonna sweep and they just like
didn't give it to her so i thought that
was weird but i don't really believe in
like getting mad
unless it's for taylor but i don't
really believe in like getting mad every
artist deserves it like if you made your
way to the grammys and you got nominated
like in one way you all deserve it so
even though i might not have chosen it
and i wasn't really familiar with his
work i thought that the grammys were a
great commercial for him because i was
like totally his energy is everything i
knew it left being like oh my god we
loved him and yeah
he is and now i'm learning so much about
him
he was like secretly married because his
wife um for the second time was
diagnosed with leukemia and so they just
like got married and it's like this
really romantic story so we're just
learning things about someone we might
not have learned and i think that's
great that is great now what did you
think about the performances and the
looks like what stood out to you um i
thought i just like stand carrie
underwood as well her performance she's
just like kills it every time i agree
with his legs i'm a country like me too
i'm a country girl throwing through me
put that dress on the red carpet like
crime crime i guess
like i just like i can't imagine she's
ever gonna hear the [ __ ] i say but like
just like
bad like really bad like i always feel
bad talking [ __ ] about someone's dress
because you know they felt so good in it
like they would never have like left but
like that was it was it was a war crime
i don't feel bad like at all because let
me tell you why um it's a dress carrie
underwood um is not her clothing and
like when you are literally releasing
songs and making millions of dollars off
of one song like i'm allowed to make fun
of your dress well who wasn't telling
her that it looked like a botched bell
you know what i actually saw tick tock
today that really spoke to me and it was
no one's i don't want to be mean but
like the women in country like
really from a fashion perspective were
disgraceful
at the grammys the best was kelsey
ballerini beautiful yeah classy classy
simple um and the rest it was you know
carrie underwood's mustard yellow moment
it was marin morris's snakeskin dress
with a bra popping out which i didn't
understand and mickey guyton's um
atrocity i didn't see mickey guys it was
velvet shoes it was fringe long sleeve
it was she's just like a young stunning
star on the rise like it was aging
yeah it was like the women in country
just did not show up fashion wise but
they did show up in every other aspect
so did country in general brothers
osborne won oh did they for like i just
watched the recap on here so i didn't
see as many performances i just keep
seeing these clips by the way i see him
i saw it on tick tock um but it was a
big deal and he talked about like coming
out and i never thought he would have it
it was just like i was so emo like the
way i would take a bullet for tj
obviously i was gonna say everyone in
town thinks that though oh good okay
everyone in town is like oh would you
ever date a country singer yeah well i
did for four years but i mean not like
i'm sorry i'm not my ex john gurney he's
a great country singer but he's not like
you know okay what about brett eldredge
for you eldridge for me that sounds
ideal but i'm pretty sure he's dating
like a supermodel right now is he yeah
he's so mysterious with his like dating
life he's so quiet he's like literally
no chase rice chase rice my best friend
dated him for three years so that's not
gonna work yeah yeah yep yeah
um you know what i'm thinking we'll keep
that we'll keep running through it i
don't know i think that i probably
i like i like that everyone in town is
like she's not a star [ __ ] yeah i like
that about me yeah i like that about you
too yeah so that's nice and i feel like
i get invited to everything no you're
not trying to like no one's like oh my
god this [ __ ] is going to come and like
flirt with everything right like we're
keeping it nice and classy and low-key
and like i like that about me that takes
a lot of restraint because i imagine if
i were you like i would be start [ __ ]
my way to the top no i'd be [ __ ] i
just try not to [ __ ] on the low i
mean i outsource the dick so we're like
we're flying out we're having people fly
in we're outsourcing the dick and then
in my town everyone's like what a saint
okay and so i like how we're just
blowing up your spot right here when you
get flown out for dick do you pay for
your own flight um i've actually never
like it'll be me already being where i'm
at and like maybe i'll meet someone or
maybe someone will set us up got it
that's nice i've never had a man buy me
a purse a flight like honestly gentlemen
i'm open to the opportunity but like
that's queen beautiful
over there like no i've never heard
about that purse herself i bought it
yesterday
yesterday she's a new girl you need like
a man to buy you a birkin like now yeah
where are they at
they're not watching i know that i know
we have a very um very straight audience
but maybe they have brothers
do you have a cousin that wants to find
me birkin give me a brother birkin yeah
you need a birkin brother um so other
than that it was like kind of boring the
grammys but it was fine love george cat
um no one in there was no like oh i
liked her outfits a lot mine
yours always um doji me too she was
probably the best dressed in my opinion
i love just like
cut outs and tie i just love sexy little
bodies yeah i think halsey also is up
there for best dressed yeah yeah yeah i
love a hat hers was really cool it was
different so
i don't know maybe my bar is super high
because of the slap but i was like when
is something crazy going to happen well
now everyone's thinking that about
everything i know should i slap you over
here please oh my god you're the only
person i would be like cool with this
um i thought trevor noah was fine trevor
noah the host
right he was fine okay
well indifferent to it obviously yeah he
was just like really professional and
like really not funny ooh do you think
he was scared because of course oh my
gosh that's actually that sad yeah of
course and i think just like in in
general beyond the slap being a host is
a thankless job like yeah it's so much
work especially if you're doing it as a
woman they have to change outfits a
thousand times and every you're always
someone's always gonna be like that was
boring that wasn't good i mean there's
no one that's just like he killed it
through someone always has something to
say about one part of it you can't win
because you're either like if you if you
really go there and say like crazy jokes
like amy schumer's getting backlash now
right or so you're boring and then
everyone's like you're boring right it's
i don't think i don't think there's a
worse job in hollywood honestly no it
and they're there for so long and half
the [ __ ] is not even your written jokes
no of course no it's like you you like
get all this backlash and you're like
wait but it wasn't right yeah like i
didn't even write your jokes right
totally the academy would let me say
them yeah um
so you know what it was fine that's
where i'm gonna leave it yeah i didn't
watch last year's ratings were like an
all-time low and they're slightly up
this year so i think people were just
tuning in to see yeah but i also think
like they tried to combat that they were
streaming on paramount plus which was
like a first you can watch it on cbs
okay so i think they thought the ratings
would be like much higher with a
streamer right um and i think that maybe
for a while we thought like award shows
were relevant because they're on cable
but now we think they're irrelevant just
because they're irrelevant not because
they're not on the street
well and we're just so like we're so
privileged with all these you and and
e-news and all these things that just
like like regurgitate it for us that we
so easily to me
i know everything that happened and i
was on stage for more than half of the
show yeah we don't have to i don't have
to watch it and i don't want to watch
the boring grammys because i can just
get the good [ __ ] the next day i know
and it's like when the real a-listers
don't come
right
i agree um okay well thanks for bringing
down the grammys with me shannon of
course and we have some more news um it
is a kardashian's heavy day but like
there's major skims news because her new
campaign is literally breaking the
internet
she has hired heidi klum tyra banks and
alessandra ambrosio
for her new oh and candice swanpo for
her new skims campaign so she is you
know kind of
eclipsing the angels the shapewear
mogul's new swims icon campaign has
supermodels tyra heidi alessandra and
candace posing together for the very
first time in the ads the four form
former victoria's secret angels show off
the skim's fits everybody collection of
thongs bras and bodysuits and kim wrote
on instagram that her shoot was a blast
she said it's been a while since we were
all together so it was so special to be
reunited and allegedly like it was just
gonna be the four of them but then kim
was there and she was like i have to get
in one photo so there's pictures of the
four and then there's pictures of them
with kim and i'm dead because like at
what point you're like i'm going to pop
in oh yeah like imagine the confidence
what was that conversation she's just
like i mean obviously kim kardashian
iconic and totally body right everything
yes everything but i just can't imagine
being like so
let me just pop in for one
i don't know also
like i think it's absolutely wild that
she had all those people in one place i
know what is their marketing budget i i
mean they're like now valued like over i
think almost two billion dollars
so they have a lot of money and so this
isn't surprising and i do feel like this
is kind of eclipsing some of the
progress victoria's secret has made in
the last couple months like victoria's
secret has made it extremely clear
that they are going to be like moving
forward like revamping the brand more
inclusive like they made huge waves when
they signed remy and they are from tick
tock which love for me and i love that
for them and i love that they they
didn't they acquire frankie's bikinis
they just bought like an 18 million
dollar stock in frankie's yeah so
they're really trying to make progress
and i feel like this is just like
shutting that down because like this is
so iconic i mean leave it to kim to just
like shut them the [ __ ] they're like
whoever's in the boardroom that's like
we've got it we've done it mark the t
dot the i and kim's like nope no yes so
that was my my first thought was like
wow this is iconic too like oh my god
victoria's secret cannot catch a break
no cannot you cannot well i mean they're
making up for a lot of i know like
they're really like they have amira from
tiktok who's amazing they have remy from
tick tock i think that they are like
really trying to undo all the damage
they did in those really toxic years
yeah but to be honest like i don't know
if a lot of people are really interested
in a victoria secret revamp because i'm
very much like a skim's girly now well i
just like can't wear victoria's secret
not feel like young like i feel like i'm
in high school i can't wear victoria's
secret period like my breasts are too
big like i literally can't wear it no
like skims when they have the fits
everybody collection like it truly fits
everybody i i literally feel like it's a
travesty that for most of my life i
thought i was a d cup because victoria's
secret makes you think do you know how
many men i was like i mean i'm a 34 d
and they were like [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
are no you aren't you're so right like
their sizing is so toxic it's so
incorrect and i feel like the first time
i learned what bra size i truly was was
when i took literally the third love
quiz because
and i was like oh my that's my actual
size and i've been moving forward with
that size now and the peace of mind and
clarity i have i've never felt more
elusive yeah well it's crazy too no one
feels good when they're wearing a size
that's labeled something different or
whatever all that just [ __ ] does not
feel good like i think people think i'm
smaller than i am this hap i was talking
about this on my instagram because
people will send me extra small [ __ ]
like
yeah yes and i'm like
i'm just not an extra small i'm really
not i'm i'm a medium yeah i just want to
wear size medium things now people are
always sending me extra small and it's
so annoying like guys i'm an extra extra
small like please get my size right get
it right all right i think any sizing
just sucks when it's like not really
correctly you just you're gonna feel bad
especially in like fast fashion where
like the size is just whack and like
when you shop online so much and then
every now and then you'll go into like a
department store and you're like by
you're you're literally taking clothes
into the dressing room that are three
four sizes bigger because that's what
you're used to buying on sheets yes it's
so toxic for like your mental health you
do that yeah i'm like okay well i'm
probably gonna go ahead and grab a xyz
in this and then i'm like wait this is
normal made clothes
this is well-made clothing so right
probably the size that i actually am but
fast fashion is it's crazy as hell it's
crazy selling it's so cheap so
everything's so small so you're
literally sizing up two three sizes no
stretch no give no nothing and that's
why i just love kim more than anything
and i i could literally write
a thesis on this like when kim did fendi
x
skip yeah it was phoenix games and like
there were not only plus size models on
the website but like literally sizes
that fendi has never made in their life
i'm like this is so
iconic like yeah it's just the fact that
this isn't the normal is so stupid and
the fact that kim was able to get fendi
to size up is just next level like
they're literally on the totem pole of
like designer brands right and like they
don't like waiver for anyone and they
don't give a [ __ ] about any like bad
like really i feel like brands that big
just don't care about yeah
they're like whatever we're going to be
iconic we're chanel with vindy or
whatever exactly so the fact that kim
kardashian could come in and like make
them sell like these three x4x sizes
iconic no and you know what i feel like
the kardashians get so much [ __ ] for
like setting an unrealistic beauty
standard chloe specifically and i don't
even want to get into that because i
don't agree with it but like there's
there's a huge conversation about it and
no one even talks about like good
american all my clothes are from good
american it's literally the best website
except their returns are like a little
[ __ ] but
like
courtney i mean kim and chloe and like
all of their brands like they're just
really making ways they're they're
walking the walk and they're talking the
talk and nobody talks about that all
they talk about is like how chloe
filters her face and she's setting it on
realistic beauty standards for women
when it's like you were also mean to her
back in the day and that's why she was
doing this right so she's just a victim
of trauma like [ __ ] off all were
literally crazy to her crazy oh my god
like like maybe one one of them like i'm
like me comparing her to princess diana
but i'm like honestly like
she was so brutally attacked i think
more than kim like of where he's way
more like him with her like pregnancies
and stuff like i know that was her own
trauma but like i it's i would be way
more [ __ ] up in the head of course
she's killing it honestly yeah and the
way that everyone is just like now
they're saying she's too skinny and her
photos are too filtered it's like why do
you think she's doing all of this like
for the years and years where like
people were the nastiest things about
her people were tweeting commenting the
meanest things like she's literally
damaged from that also could you imagine
someone saying that you're too big your
whole life and then you like work out
twice a day eat healthy have a chef and
you get like fit as [ __ ] and then
someone's like ugh you're too skinny
you're setting up realistic body
standards smoke would literally come out
of my ears i'd be like i know like
what
i prefer to focus on
the good things that the kardashians are
doing and i think a lot of people don't
talk about how like skims good american
fendi x games like really are
changing the game game changers game
changers i agree i love good american
like i think they're like i stand good
american i've done brand deals with them
before
i've recently started to buy literally
pretty much exclusively from yes and i
love their sizing because it's not small
medium margin no one wants to buy
something that's like extra large it's
like embarrassing totally so they have
one two three four five six like that is
stunning yeah i love stunning i also
love that i also love that whenever i
work with them as a brand deal they like
let a lot of brands are so picky about
messaging and they really were like do
what you want we trust you oh i love
that and i appreciated that i was like
i'll cover the the topics that you need
to cover but can i say it the way that i
want to say it and a lot of brands are
like very strict i mean they're like
they don't they don't trust these hoes
but i'm like trust me i trust worthy
hope yeah i love good american i'm so
glad you're on the same page um so
skim's just like being iconic yet again
i'm so happy like that skins is doing as
well as we all thought it would be yes
and i'm so glad it's not called kimono i
almost just said remember when they
change the name and now she's doing the
same thing with her perfume well she's
changing kkw fragrances obviously
because she's not kkw kkkw beauty as
well i'm sure then right right so kkw
beauty has been like shut down for a
couple months they're like rebranding
the formula rebranding whatever so i do
believe like kkw beauty and fragrance
will come back as one company which they
should it should yeah and i don't know
what it's going to be called i kind of
forgot she did perfume and that's kind
of where she started i know which is so
crazy but she was like doing this whole
like repertoire and like giving this
like back like you guys from the moment
i can't with gardenia i was like what
the [ __ ] i don't remember any of this
oh my god i thought it was so crazy that
people were buying perfumes online that
they've never smiled that sucks which by
the way i remember being like i want
this obviously because i am such a basic
[ __ ] and i was online and i was like
reading the notes and it was like i
don't know what this means what is like
a i bought the sample pack oh good good
good you know i did do that but it's
crazy because i did smell two of them
like ooh yeah no i know it's like the
fact that kkw fragrances was as
successful as it was and nobody ever
smelled it
it's so crazy no wait i didn't realize
that no one [ __ ] smelled it no it's
psychotic
it's the craziest thing that's the power
of kim kardashian that is crazy so we
love skims over here we're big
supporters and speaking of more
kardashian drama kanye west has dropped
out of coachella with less than two
weeks before the festival begins and i'm
really over talking about kanye but i do
feel like this is a positive development
because kim did he drop out or did they
pull him he dropped out and it was
reported that allegedly he told kim he
was going to stop and then go away and
get some help i saw that so i feel like
this is part of that okay well then here
i'm here for that meeting i'm actually
going to coachella and um which i can't
tell if it's my worst nightmare or if
i'm gonna have fun
i went one time but i only went for one
day because my flight my fights got
messed up and i was delayed like three
days in dallas so i feel like i didn't
even i went there for um a brand deal at
the time i took a photo in front of the
ferris wheel and then left yeah because
it was so late and botched so i haven't
experienced it that way and um gordon's
evolved so like they've done like the
whole
i feel like it'll be they'll take care
of everything yeah so that'll be posh
and fun and cool but like i don't really
love like the outside you know no i know
can i tell you i've been twice and
before i went for the first time like it
was my idea of hell um and i was like so
negative about it that's how i think i'm
being yeah but then like you get there
and first of all you really don't go to
the festival until the night and it gets
so much cooler like it's not that hot oh
okay and it's kind of like everything
really i know it's like so lame and i'm
trusting you on this but and i'm the
most negative [ __ ] alive like i
hated coachella and i had never even
been and we went me and jackie for a
brand deal so we didn't really have like
a bunch of things planned we ended up
having like a really good time that the
next year like we fully planned out like
we got a house
yeah like we had a good time i don't
think i would ever go back again it's
definitely something you should
experience right revolve makes it really
premium the parties are so fun they have
amazing performers so it's it's honestly
not the worst okay stage coaches better
are you going to stage coach i'm going
to stage coaching with me and that'll be
really good okay i'll be there too okay
um but i agree with kanye yeah i think i
like this i like this for him i think
it's like pulling out to do that but i
feel like he always does this and it's
kind of like so toxic toxic and he
really is like it's like the i mean i
hate to use these like triggering words
but like it's the abusive ex that like
does this stuff and then he comes back
and he's like i promise i'm getting i
know and i feel bad for him because he
obviously has admitted that he has
mental illness
yeah so i'm just like i
i really feel like it's such a constant
stream of and now i'm gonna go away be
better and i'm gonna come back and
everyone's gonna which again i love his
music i know of course if i could
separate the two from church and state
like right really obviously love his
music but i just feel so bad for him me
too i feel so bad for her and i feel
like she's probably if i was her i'd be
thinking okay he's going to go away and
come back and it's just
not going to do it five years from now
yeah so like i've really been annoyed
with kanye in recent weeks and like
really not even wanting to talk about
the stuff because at the end of the day
like we can all like eat eat up the
gossip and everything right but it's
kim's life and this is harassment and
there's this happens to a million people
who don't have security all this stuff
totally so i'm like i i really am like
annoyed with him and i'm glad that i
think we're at the end of it now and
he'll yeah go and see i hope yeah but do
you think her and um peter gonna get
married okay so like
the way we've talked about kim and p
like the evolution has really changed
because at first it was like yes this is
the perfect bachelor bounce back rebound
right and now like it's just reported
like kim met his grandparents she came
to staten island this weekend like i and
and then like seeing the text messages
of like him defending kim yeah to kanye
like yes the way he's branded yeah i
know the way that
i am so
obsessed with this couple like i am it's
not healthy and i never thought i would
like like want this for kim but i think
that like she's having the time of her
life i think she had like a good
marriage that like in the last few years
was really hard and she hasn't like been
in love in a few years and i think she's
like having this whirlwind romance and
i'm obsessed scared i think she's
literally been scared and i think if i
was kim if i was kardashian i think that
i would be like who the [ __ ] do i date
next and i know it's like she could date
anyone so she's like who do i date next
and i think like when i see pictures of
them i literally am like she's so happy
right now that [ __ ] is getting digged
down in dallas and she is happy yeah
she's happy and i just like it i'm
getting over it but so people are saying
here's who's going to replace kanye okay
which by the way i feel like a lot of
people didn't even look at the
performers for coachella
i think a lot of people bought tickets
like to see kanye so i think a lot of
people might be like really disappointed
yeah but they're saying maybe the
weekend
maybe justin bieber okay maybe uh tyler
the creator okay so he was the headliner
correct okay so this is pretty crazy
then that he just dropped the [ __ ] i
mean the headliner because like when you
watch um i don't know if you've seen the
i don't know if it's a documentary or uh
whatever it was with um homecoming with
it shows yes beyonce it shows the the
work that they put in months it's months
and months and months it's performance
it's stage work it's all dancing
choreography it's crazy and then i was
at coachella of the year that ariana
grande was there and i remember watching
being like there's a spaceship now this
how do they do all this how does she
know all this where she know her feet go
and then i was like oh they do this for
it's like the pen it's a pinnacle for
people right now it's like a super bowl
half time exactly it is i would say
these step one of the steps below yeah
agreed and so because it's just like so
sought after and it just the the
preparation yeah like the preparedness
yeah the preparation for it is wild so
yeah who the [ __ ] is two weeks away do
you think they'll do someone that's
already done it that like kind of or
maybe someone that's on tour currently
that has an opening because they're
already like you know choreographed and
stuff yeah um or someone that requires
very little like someone who's more
understated like who doesn't right like
an ed chair just a man in his guitar
have you ever been to one of his shows i
have and i literally thought it was the
worst concert i'd ever been to i cried i
thought it was the best concert
i would put in my top three well because
i love his music so do i by the way but
i was like this is crazy he has
absolutely no overhead for this whole
like my brain and his little pedal his
pedal and his guitar and i'm like okay i
get it that's really that doesn't change
nothing changes i think the biggest
venue you can do with that kind of style
is maybe in arena i saw him at a stadium
it was outside there's like helicopters
i'm like i can't even hear this [ __ ]
like it was so quiet i saw him in a
stadium but i was i was in a box so they
feed this i was in a box tuba they beat
it through maybe i got nothing said to
me okay they fed ours through and so we
were just like having the best time but
like honestly i remember just all i
could think about was like the finances
behind it all i was like he is [ __ ]
cashing out not having to pay anyone no
you're 100 right like that's why
comedians make so much money when they
tour because it's literally a man and a
stool there's no overhead right and so
that's i was thinking the exact same
thing when i saw ed sheeran i'm like no
this tour and it's a stadium tour like
he's making millions there's also just
no i was kidding about him like
headlining coachella like no everyone
would be like what the no it's so low
energy like yeah i like what everyone's
on molly they're like a lot of people
are hoping it's taylor i think taylor
first of all would never replace kanye
like oh she's too like she was proud she
would never i think just a lot of people
are like hopefully good
to replace someone of kanye stature you
need like a kanye and ariana
i'm not a kind of a tailor an ariana
beyonce like that's the name like that
you need damn i wonder if beyonce would
do it again you know that's an
interesting take that people don't want
to touch the replacement of kanye right
because it's like it's icky it's like
sloppy seconds yeah well no i think
anyone would be happy to like just be
like yeah i'll fill in but i just feel
like people wouldn't want to like you
said like they're now associated with
the
you know what i actually think justin
bieber is the perfect person to do it i
agree he's on tour right now so like his
show's already choreographed i don't
know if he has like the day available he
might have a show that day but i do
think he would be perfect for it and
he's friends with kanye so it's not a
big deal not weird and he's like just as
big he's just as big has he done
coachella before i don't think so so
that's the only thing i could see him
being like i'm not gonna half-ass at my
first right now you want to have like
the announcement like yeah with the
whole thing okay i'm very interested in
this me too but like people like pay a
lot of money to be there literally so
like you need to really step your [ __ ]
up
step the [ __ ] up the [ __ ] for us do
you think the weekend would be an
appropriate fill-in you know i love the
weekend's music but i just have never
like gotten down with him like i don't
think i could watch a whole weekend show
i remember he did was it super bowl
where he was in the mirrors yeah he was
like like whatever and i just remember
being like i just
i'm not like
popping my [ __ ] yeah i'm not obsessed
i'm not obsessed it was more art and i
understand that it was definitely more
like artistic than it was like a bang
like a bangers right like you're not
head banging yeah but i mean people love
the weekend and he can totally like like
i think people on drugs would really
like to see the weekend i know you
really have to take in that factor of
the drugs i saw gaga and it was
life-changing yeah yeah okay gaga was
like would be like a top performer i
feel like she was at coachella yeah okay
that was the first time we went and
that's like me and jackie had a brand
deal so we were like
every song you don't realize you know
every song what you do you know every
gaga song every single one and they're
all i mean they're all like
head boppers no and like even people
like people like coachella are very like
alternative like
yeah like i love like i can't really
like
and so i thought like a lot of people
wouldn't have been into gaga but like
she just has a way about her like yeah
everyone [ __ ] slaps everybody loves
scaring also like yes and quite the
performer anytime you see anytime i see
any of your interviews and stuff i'm i'm
endeared to her like i like because
there could be a hundred people in a
room yes totally and 99 of them don't
believe in you but i believe in you
shannon thank you so much um pink is
like starting drama in our next story
and your merch yeah yeah oh yeah sorry i
totally forgot to promote new merch
sneak peek oh can't say
okay pink is mocking rolling stone
magazine you've been irrelevant since
1990. so they posted on instagram
um like this picture of
promoting an article like 25 of the best
grammy's performances
to talk about the grammys and then i
guess they left her off of it and she
has did she perform
in recent history she has she was doing
aerobics you know she was singing up in
the air er you know she they met in
general in general not this year just
like in history before the grammys
premiered on sunday they were like watch
back some of the best and they left her
out of it and they posted a picture on
instagram like top 25 whatever and the
picture that they had posted was a
picture of taylor swift and was like
here are 25 click the link in our bio to
see the top 25 grammy's performances and
i guess they left pink out of it and
they used a picture of taylor swift to
promote and pink has been like
not overly but like she's been critical
of taylor swift in recent years you have
seen especially on watch weapons live
like before taylor
back in the day when taylor used to like
not talk about politics right pink was
like giving her [ __ ] for it um so i just
feel like there's tension there which
breaks my heart because like these are
two queens i just like all these flavors
and she chose salt that's just crazy
i wouldn't be i think it speaks more
that she's affected by an article by
rolling stones if you're saying you've
been irrelevant since 1990 they they
hold space in your head right like
they're living rent-free this is what
she wrote
you guys have been irrelevant since
1990. this is the magazine that used to
feature people
like john lennon and muddy waters hunter
s thompson wrote political pieces they
put tina turner on their cover then they
sold out and all credibility went to
[ __ ] when style over substance and
revenue over authenticity went into play
that's when snooki became acceptable
coverage give me a [ __ ] break do your
homework you don't have to like me or my
music or anything about me and believe
me i could give a [ __ ] sounds like you
do give a [ __ ] um but this is the
biggest sellout in [ __ ] history when
it comes to a publication we all once
trusted [ __ ] rolling stone and i felt
that way for many decades and so many
met it's really long and so many of my
favorite hold on it's loading it's
really long and so many of my favorite
artists and peers have this isn't just
about their horrendous opinion of
raiding grammy performances it's decades
of wasting trees and people's time oh my
god i just introduced into it i didn't
think she had to really bring snooki
into that like honestly i i thought that
was actually kind of [ __ ] up wait i
when when you said that i was like oh
rude i do like leave snooki out of this
she's just doing her best she's doing
her best and she never claimed to be
like a single stone's acclaimed artist
like she's just out here eating pickles
and like living her best life putting
her ass in a mini fridge i know and
she's like come a long way honestly i
don't know just for snooki is what this
whole podcast should be about because i
just and what a like random little blurb
she threw in there like right like pick
someone that's done like really mean
things to people and like use them as
you're like blurb right like someone we
can all get behind a true villain yeah i
would that that was jarring when you
read that part i was like oh rude no i
know it's like leave snooki out of it
and i get what uh pink is saying like
first of all she should be included in
that artist list whatever it's not the
biggest deal it's not
it's not facts it's just like this dumb
article like listicle from rolling stone
actually buzzfeed at this point like
right exactly
we know that people aren't going to like
the stores and rarely are people picking
them up so honestly like all these
publications are having to put out so
many internet so much content because
everyone's consuming so much online so
like i mean it was probably just a
really dumb filler article like i know
and now she's like bringing so much
attention to it and honestly the whole
message she wrote is like about how she
doesn't give a [ __ ] but like you don't
spend that much time writing a magilla
when you don't care like you obviously
care rent-free they're in your head
right
like
so not pink like i watch her a
documentary and she really is that [ __ ]
like she doesn't give a [ __ ] so what are
you doing what are you doing this is
like kind of like a losery thing on pink
i want to say i think that i think it's
very um loser behavior yeah which makes
me sad because pink is not a loser like
no any
schnookie by the way no snooki is
amazing leave snooki out of it i just
think leave her out i'm feeling like
chris cracker like leaves
it's really not cool and
this is kind of lose her behavior from
she's also like she's always kind of
brought women up and i just yeah it's
like it was just that's just weird it's
really unlike her i'm like shook
yeah it feels like a it feels like very
like um sore loser behavior i know and
it's like not even something worth
fighting over it's a stupid argument i
know
it was she like it's giving me red vibes
yeah i'm not
she's like i don't even care yeah and
you're like
um
she stated like three times like i don't
get i don't care as if i could give a
[ __ ] like uh you're quaking
you're quaking no you wrote like a long
ass comment like you had to wait for a
character yeah right you care pink and
that's fine it's okay to care like i
think it's time we start normalizing
like caring what other people think
about you because like you're upset yeah
nobody on the planet cares more about me
what other people think than me so i
totally get it but it's kind of illusory
to like act like you don't care when
your actions are clearly saying
otherwise
yeah that's always like i always try to
not say i don't care because i care so
[ __ ] much about so many things so
deeply even when i don't care and i say
i don't care i'm like people aren't
buying it yeah i'm like always that
[ __ ] like i don't give a [ __ ] if you
knew how many times i cried myself
like i care a lot i'd be caring i became
i mean i mean i i try to keep that
narrative pretty good you can call me
karen i'm karen i'm [ __ ] karen no
[ __ ] too long for me to get that one i i
just like i think i'm pretty honest and
open about like how articles like
[ __ ] suck of course i have to
physically just like not look at them
other because if i if i look at it i'm
gonna be karen you have such a strong
accent where are you from from really
you think it's southern are you southern
i'm from south carolina yeah yeah you
sound like hella southern wow okay
people say that people in the south say
i don't sound southern at all oh and
then people outside of the south they're
like where are you from yeah you are so
you're you live in asheville but you're
from south carolina yeah so it's just
like south south south like yeah so
southern yeah
i like it i won't talk like that too
that was not good
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i don't know who
you are
but i think like so i grew up watching
honey boo boo and that's the influence
oh okay honey was good the best show on
tv they're really good honestly hate to
see the downfall the families
really really tough but if you want to
go back and watch old episodes i highly
recommend but i also recommend that you
don't eat because it's like one of the
most disgusting shows they're always
like they're like throwing mayo at each
other like it's real they're like just
like fisting cheese balls and then
they're like one of them has like an
extra toe and they're like always
playing with the toe it's really sick it
really is it's sick it's like borderline
like one of those t well it wasn't it's
tlc oh my god i was like it's gonna be
like i don't even i skipped past tlc so
fast because even the titles of the show
i'm like thousand pound sisters yes
what's the one the ordering the hoarding
ones quarters you're not with quarters
buried alive
they're actually buried alive don't
forget about my 19-pound scrotum
i want to yeah no you shouldn't forget
about it sister wives a classic oh you
know what i got really into back in the
day uh gypsy
um uh gypsy weddings yes oh my god i i
mean my mom would have to peel me away
from the tv and then one time i went to
this little town in south carolina that
was like i don't know i think i was
trying to buy like a prom dress for
cheaper and um i was like wow some of
these dresses and she was like you know
we were on what is this was it my big
fat gypsy wedding my big fat gypsy
wedding okay i know we were on that and
i was like
sold shut the [ __ ] up i'm getting one
here this the chokehold that that show
had me in first of all the way they
would get into those threats
no fights oh like at the wedding at the
ceremony beating the [ __ ] out of each
other oh and the dresses i mean and they
always looked like actual like character
like yeah and that's just what they were
doing yeah it was so wild and then it
was also like so weird that they were
getting married at like 14. yeah oh yeah
oh it was also cringey but i get could
it was the tlc show that i could not
have been a chokehold i'm so glad you
just brought that up because like i
totally had forgotten about that show
and like i was uh you need to go back
and watch it because like the amount of
work these women were putting in these
dresses to get into those dresses they
were literal like the size of a trailer
yes and then some of the women that were
making them were like yeah i'll only do
two dresses a year because i'll pay for
my whole salary for the whole year
because it also takes me six months to
make it right and the crazy thing was
that these people like literally lived
in squalor and they just like saved up
every single dollar for the wedding for
the wedding like they didn't spend money
on anything they live in campers right
like just to save for the wedding crazy
also i really liked wife swap that i
still of course i quote king curtis like
daily did you ever watch sister wives
sister wives no i didn't get into that
it's still on the air oh really and
there's a lot of drama one of the
watches just left oh how long have they
been sisters and friends well they have
been wives and sisters since i was in
high school that's when i started
watching the show so eleventh grade like
two that's a long standing show it's a
long marriage too they're all it's not
they're not jumping from different like
men with there's one man four wives
same same family this whole time yeah
wow it's deep and they've kind of been
run out of like they used to live in
utah then because polygamy like is not
legal yeah so they were like run out of
utah then they went to nevada then
arizona and i think they're backing you
it's illegal at least one state probably
florida i don't think it's illegal
anywhere
but i'm not a hundred percent illegal
anywhere no i think it might be legal in
nevada that's it damn yeah so it's
really interesting i'm learning a lot
from tlc yeah tlc we have a few more
stories that are brought to you by
manscaped ladies have you started spring
cleaning yet the carpets need cleaning
the drapes need dusting and you and your
man's lawn need mowing
spring is sprung and the global leaders
in below the waist grooming have the
best tools for cleaning aisle 5 in your
pants join the other 4 million
individuals worldwide who have trusted
manscaped by going to manscape.com for
20 off and free shipping with the code
toast manscaped has the full package
your household needs for spring cleaning
this year the performance package 4.0 is
the only tool you need to keep the lawn
smooth and smelling fresh help them
smell the roses with the weed whacker of
the nose and ear hair trimmer and they
provide provide proprietary skin safe
technology which helps prevent nicks
snags and tugs on your sensitive areas
manscaped is also committed to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men which is age 15 to 35 and
giving support for fighters survivors
and families impacted by testicular
cancer as a part of their we save balls
collection
so with the start of testicular cancer
awareness month in april manscape has
partnered with the testicular cancer
society to bring awareness to testicular
cancer men's health and early cancer
detection get 20 off and free shipping
with code toast at manscape.com that's
20 off plus free shipping with the
codetoast.manscape.com
ben loves manscaped we use all of their
products out with the old grooming
habits and in with the new at manscaped
all right shannon are you ready to keep
going how are you feeling so far i'm
feeling good i really liked all the
verbiage of that ad yes you're balls
girly yeah i'm so inappropriate i just
like i love i'm like a child well
personally i can't participate in any
activities where balls fly at my nose so
you don't like them no it's equivalent
clueless well there goes your social
life sorry oops okay next up this is
like the breaking news of the day i
don't know why you're gonna have like a
really interesting story of why you
can't have balls like here no when amber
gets a nose job i can't participate in
activities where balls fly at my nose in
gym class um this is the breaking news
of the day and i don't know why i buried
it so hard but kourtney kardashian and
travis parker are married shook
to my court when you told me this i said
it just happened i go yes i go i have
chills
so basically the grammys were in vegas
they were there because travis performed
with someone i can't remember this is
confirmed like hundo percentage it's
from tmz which pretty much means it's
confirmed okay so they were in vegas and
allegedly they eloped at a las vegas
chapel at 1 30 in the morning local time
and tmz is reported um the insiders told
the outlet that kardashian 42 and barker
46 didn't allow the venue to take
pictures
they brought their own photographer and
security and the keeping up with star
and the blink 182 drummer reportedly
asked for an elvis presley impersonator
to officiate the ceremony however this
will not be the pda packed lovebirds
only wedding according to the report
sources also said that there will be
several other celebrations in the future
lots of fanfare and i quote um so they
just got married legally this reminds me
of when joe jonas and sophie turner got
married after the grammys and diplo was
there because they were getting married
abroad and they needed a legal license
so they did in vegas which i thought was
like so cute and funny i thought it was
cute um like his brothers were there
because it was like somewhat planned but
it was still an appointment so this is
just like so uncourting because she's
like they're so family oriented yeah
wait so her family wasn't there i don't
think so they weren't in vegas they were
so mad that diploma blew up their spot
right i like wished someone blew up
there so i want to see pics from i know
i'm sure we actually will see
i could see them not doing like a super
formal wedding and i could say wait wait
wait never mind i take that back she's
never been married before i know and
like as much as they're like so kind of
like crazy emo weird they're also like
very traditional
so i kind of think we'll be getting like
a big catholic wedding they're very
religious the kardashians they are like
i thought that the engagement was so
like traditional it was almost it was
almost kind of chewy yes i like
completely like like when i thought i
was like ew no i know that's like so not
travis bart yeah i was like not the
heart-shaped rose right no it's a
hundred percent i couldn't have said it
better myself yeah so okay so i'm i'm
shocked that they're they did that but
also i'm just gonna say and like i'm
standing standing at courtney being
happy right now all the kardashians are
just seeing in the best season falling
into the right like dude the right dudes
are falling into the kardashians yes
okay so i'm happy for that but i also
like low-key think that getting married
in vegas in a loping is also kind of
chewy yeah it was cute whenever sophia
sophie and um jojo did it because
because they still had a full wedding
and this was like before you get married
in italy you need an american marriage
license so it was kind of like two birds
one stone it was like a funny cool
moment after the grammys right but then
it was also you know they're getting
married maybe they're doing it abroad
too maybe
i just feel like it's it's um it's
varied them in the sense that they're
like rocker or whatever right but it's
right also just
yeah okay i mean i guess whatever i hope
that they're like filming this for the
hulu show which premieres literally in
10 days
they have to there's no no i know she's
poorly so like you know boundaries
boundaries yeah but she's been a better
sport i feel like she's been showing a
lot like i would have never guessed you
would show like her engagement oh yeah
yeah the journey when they said that
they i don't know a lot of times on
reality tv like when people don't have
anything to talk about they like say
they're going to try for more kids like
we've seen that totally on housewives so
many times so many times and it's kind
of like filler so i'm really hoping
that's not the case because i would love
to see a bar kardashian child i dead
asking if they want to have kids i think
so too because they're so obsessed with
one another i'm also just like such a
like i will follow the kardashians into
the abyss so i'm like i believe them
they want to have babies no and they've
really said like in no uncertain terms
that this show is very different from
the e-show the e-show especially towards
the end was filled with so much dumb
like fake like
pranks i was looking at the pranks like
i couldn't and they made it seem like
that's what he really wanted and that
this is very like documentary style much
more real so i have to imagine what
we're seeing is truthful that's gonna be
hard for them because i bet when they
showed up to work every day they're like
we know we gotta do the thing we gotta
do that we gotta shake the salad we
gotta dress up as each other we gotta
call [ __ ] uh
like i wonder if they're like damn it's
kind of hard to beat this real
entrepreneur harder work for sure yeah
but you know but they're also doing it
on their own terms just needs to get up
and work no you need to get your [ __ ]
ass up and work because honestly it
seems like no one wants to work these
days nobody that's so you just surround
yourself with people that want to work
work
um so so happy for courtney travis like
i do really stan yeah um i need kim and
pete to like follow in these footsteps
because i'm so obsessed and i see a
bromance brewing between scott and pete
they keep like posting they are on
instagram um scott took a video uh they
all have these like really cool golf
carts that chris got them all for
christmas
and pete was driving kim's pink one yeah
like dropped something off at scott's
house and scott took a video and pete
would get along a hundred percent like
degenerative total totally funny
degenerative they're like they're like
the spin-off of jackass bad boys yeah i
love it i love it and there's a bunch of
youtubers
i love that scott is still in the fold
because like even though he's messed up
many a time i do have a safe space in my
heart for him i do as well but he needs
to stop at the underage girls it's odd
it's disgusting and they all look the
same exactly and they all go through not
skinny not fat amanda we love her she
she just talked about how the
transgression of like once it's like the
scott disk effect after he like are they
in things with him because they have
like the best season in their life yes
they become like these classy sophia
richie is like unreal in the best place
yes i also like love her is it her
husband or her i don't know she married
i don't know but he's so sexy to me yeah
i don't know what he looks like because
he's like a nobody but yeah but happy
for him tall and hot love that for her
yeah um okay well we do have six stories
just because i thought this was
interesting and i wanted to get your
take on it um elon musk has snagged a
twitter board seat after buying the
largest stake in the us social network
so twitter announced this morning via
tweet and a filing with u.s securities
and exchange commissions that elon musk
who's obviously known for paypal spacex
tesla is joining the social network's
board of directors news broke earlier in
the week that elon had purchased more
than 9 stake in the social media company
after criticizing its speech policies in
late march
the news that the technology
entrepreneur had purchased several
billion dollars worth of twitter stocks
sent into shares of the company very
high yesterday
and then the twitter ceo announced this
morning in a series of tweets saying i'm
excited to share that we are appointing
elon musk to our board through
conversations with elon in recent weeks
it has become clear to us that he would
bring great value to our board he's both
passionate and intense critic of the
service which is exactly what we need on
twitter and in the boardroom to make us
stronger in the long term welcome elon
so i'm just like really jealous of the
fact that like you know you can like not
like something in a company so you just
buy it and change it like i want to have
enough money to buy tick-tock and then
give myself more follow-ups yeah you
know shadow man i i listen to you in
hand
we're like
air quotes
no i see you pop up on my feet too but i
think it does it's very curated to what
you want and i want you so that's so
sweet um i think that's iconic to be
like not interested in what you're doing
i'll buy you right let me just do it
better yeah i wonder if he's gonna like
really really change it up and do they
let board members change it up that much
just because they're a board member i
don't know right i mean i do think that
twitter is obviously like open to his
suggestions because he could have bought
the nine percent stake and not gotten a
board seat but they gave him one yeah
right right so twitter is [ __ ]
irrelevant so like elon musk is out here
making news about twitter like they
should be grateful they should be giving
him more stock i agree there's there are
people out there that are twitter stands
still they're like only the funny [ __ ]
happens on twitter and i actually don't
agree like toxic [ __ ] goes down on
twitter like if you have a lot of
followers on twitter you're toxic yeah
and i just like the fact that they make
you make such short little blurbs like i
have more to say yeah and i just like
when did queen's nothing comes across
correctly on twitter i don't think and i
just think what i should do i want to
delete mine sorry elon i deleted
yeah i just wanna just i'm not
interested in it it's just not it's not
even good it's fun anyway sorry elon
that was a poor business mistake i think
i know but i kind of love just like the
boss ass energy absolutely of just
buying something that you need to fix
yeah i was telling you about the bodega
i'm like i buy the boat again yeah right
and then they'll start remembering your
name they'll start calling your boss
shannon you know they'll start calling
you boss i love that if you had
unlimited money like what company would
you buy i would really buy tick tock i'm
dead serious because one i think it's a
good investment yeah i think that's a
great investment and two like then i
would finally get more followers yes i
would just like make myself like tom
from myspace right where everyone
everyone has to when they make one
that's like he's on there you can't
remove them as a friend
and then like everyone i don't like i
would take their um checks away yeah no
not in their checks their whole accounts
i would disable it i would just go into
the office every day be like who's
starting stuff on with me today yeah
like delete delete that's good twitter
was doing a lot of that
um yeah i'm trying to think of a company
that i would just oh mayonnaise i would
buy duke's helmets dukes
i'm a duke's girl i don't know what that
is i'm sorry there's the duke's
mayonnaise oh my god there's this like
whole skit on youtube that's so funny
it's all these like it's like [ __ ]
southern women say and that's like
iconic line is like oh she eats egg
salad and she's like oh she didn't use
dukes and i've never even heard of dukes
dukes is iconic okay so you would buy
dukes yeah i actually have a duke's
trucker hat and i wear it on airplanes a
lot just because i had on an airplane
and whatever what kind of changes would
you make internally at dukes or nothing
i would blow their spot i would give
them funnier commercials i just really
want more i want more people to know
about dukes as well because i've never
heard of it i don't feel like they're
getting the recognition that they
deserve i completely agree but when i
was on an airplane they were like she
was like is that a duke's hat i was like
yeah and she was like oh and i was like
good choice
you need like don't come at me you need
starting male fights don't come at me
i get removed i get my tsa pre-check
taken away for a fight over mayo um well
elon musk happy for you we'd love to see
investors investing you know that's
great no it's good for them yeah if elon
wants to invest in the morning toast
like we believe in free speech and
absolutely we um are beautiful stunning
and smart so we'll take an investment
we'll take six billion dollars for two
percent i'll start when you i love all
those tick tocks there are people
walking into the boardroom they're like
me going to my dad asking you guys
i'm asking for
six million dollars for zero percent
return
i love those tick tocks too um well
shannon congratulations you made it
through your fast five and actually made
it six so it was a little hard for you
and i think you did amazing sweetie so
much it's honestly it's tense coming in
here because you really are just like
iconic and i couldn't like uh reverb off
of what hannah burner said more than
just like it does feel like a check mark
in just life to be here and i'm very
grateful i love you we're not done with
you yet we still have one more segment
for you and that's the unburden yourself
segment that i'm really excited about
today's are super funny and they're
brought to you by movement in a tiny
apartment in southern california two
college dropouts teamed up to create a
watch company that broke all the rules
they have fair prices unexpected colors
and clean original designs movement is
one of the fastest growing brands
selling watches shipping over to 160
countries across the globe they've now
expanded into blue light glasses that
protect your eyes from screens they have
minimalist jewelry and more style
essentials that don't break the bank and
they're all designed out of their
california headquarters so their watches
have an unbeatable price point they have
the look and quality of a watch that's
400 to 500
at a department store but you are
getting a fraction of the cost because
they were built online and they own the
process from start to finish at movement
you'll get a beautiful watch shipped
right to your door for free and if you
don't love it you can ship it right back
for free and the blue light glasses
which i'm personally a really big fan of
because i spent a lot of time in front
of my computer my phone especially
before bed and the ever scroll blue
light fill blue light filtering glasses
are a game changer i leave them on my
nightstand and before a bed when i'm
watching tv or scrolling on tik tok um i
wear them and it really helps me with
eye strain and i fall asleep a lot
faster um and the frames are really
modern really cute if you want to
elevate your look with style that
doesn't break the bank then join the
movement and get 15 off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
mvmt.com
toast again that's mbmt.com
toast all right are you ready i'm ready
we have three girlies unburdening
themselves i love this for them and
we're just gonna try and make them feel
better you know sometimes it's really
hard but we try not to shame but like
you know yeah anything happens hello
ladies this isn't so crazy as i've done
much much worse but on saturday i was
out and drunk at the bar i was texting
this guy that i'd been dating to come
out but he wasn't up to it and it was
getting late so he was likely going to
sleep which is why he didn't answer my
last text at around 12 45 i left the bar
and i would not give up on trying to get
him to come over or meet me out oh no so
i texted him a few times in a row saying
sos and help are you awake
of course he facetimed me immediately
asking if i was okay i had to pretend
that i got spooked by something while i
was waiting for my uber to not seem like
a crazy girl who cried wolf anyway i
feel a little insane for it but i'm glad
that i'm getting it off my chest he
still didn't come over
of course he didn't come over you're
unwell honest oh sorry i'm trying not to
shame um that's not good in the future
like do not
waste an emergency like that's not good
no man is worth like you know
also that is just like it's not good
crazy behavior
like again not shaming you but just like
we are both kind of blown away by this
so what does that say i just think
moving forward just don't
do that ever again
i completely agree you could just not do
that i don't even know other ways like
send a titty pick like there are other
ways to get his attention yeah or just
like i think like if a dude isn't giving
you attention like he'll remember that
you didn't care and then they are all
the same [ __ ] idiots i love it it's
so sad but like that's it's so basic
like i think people literally have like
a whole podcast dedicated to dating and
with a with a hetero relationship and
just like a straight man like all you
have to do is ignore them and like
literally you'll be married in a week so
crazy they're literally such little
titty suckers on their moms at first and
then you yeah they're just like they
just need attention so bad and if guy's
not talking to you it's because he's
talking to someone else because men need
constant entertainment and attention and
we i just talked about smartpak because
actually so like uh i just think if he's
not responding he either is dead ass
tired or he's [ __ ] someone else so
just we're gonna just have to let that
sleeping dog lie it's not that
complicated that's what's so sad you
know like there's just so many dicks you
could hop on like i know many and you
sat and you listened to the toaster
obviously beautiful stunning and smart
so i would just
there's no need to jump through so many
hoops to get someone's attention and
honestly maybe if like you have to be
getting
doing all these crazy things to be
getting someone's attention like it's
not right for you no no no finding sleep
you're less sleepy guys yeah sneaky link
that's up late yeah and don't
make false alarms that's not cool no no
okay good morning beautiful
and stunning smart jackie and claudia
she meant shannon for sure but jackie is
yes of course love you jackie i would
like to unburden myself from a baby
shower incident i uploaded an instagram
story of the table setting at the bridal
at the baby shower without realizing
that there was background audio of my
grandmother whispering and asking me how
much weight i have lost
and me replying to her with the amount
it was live on my story for about two
hours hopefully people just thought hmm
weird flex but okay like i wanted to die
and my mama was quite remorseful about
her comment that was made in public love
you too oh no i feel you do not need to
unburden yourself from yes you did
nothing wrong like a queen you're proud
of yourself you know you should be
telling more people yeah it's so hard to
lose weight and if you wanted to do it
you did it you accomplished your goal
you should be proud of it and this
really isn't that bad like think of all
the things your grandma could have said
you know my gosh no mama should have
been shouting this from the rooftop
she's just proud of you she should have
been whispering like not no i think that
this is totally fine like you shouldn't
be embarrassed at all like it's it's
great it's great and you're celebrating
your friend's baby like what's better
yeah and maybe there was someone who's
like been like into you that like didn't
know how to like approach you or
something and he's like you know i've
been noticing that you're looking good
my mom's right and this is a great
little opener for him right it was a
great opener like oh congrats you know
maybe he didn't know what to say but now
you open the door and then you're gonna
be married and you're gonna be thinking
your grandma i think you're killing it
and i have put so [ __ ] more like
horrible things on my instagram
like by accident like just oh i should
have unburdened myself this past weekend
please what'd you do um someone was
taking an instagram story of like all
these girly pops like on on the we were
all like cheers espresso martinis and in
your nipple no no i wish in the
background but you didn't see my face
but like i just have a decently
recognizable voice slash everyone that
we were with was all like married and i
think if you knew the group you're with
you just knew shannon was saying this
and i was like oh my god i was like
that's the fifth uncircumcised dick i've
seen in the last four months
oh my god that is so cute it wasn't
until like three like two hours later
that like because it was one of those
things where everyone was like cheers
background got back to girly pop talk
and then someone started getting so many
dms it has like a lot of followers that
was like all i can hear is this is my
fourth uncircumcised dickens
that is so funny have you ever
accidentally like shown your nipple in a
dress or anything yeah but um i do it on
purpose sometimes i love that i've got
the palest nipples like i have two eyes
they are the exact same color as my skin
you can't see them like right before i
hook up with someone i'm like giving
myself titty twisters trying to like
wake up wake up wake up because i just
like wish they were darker i talked
about getting them tattooed on at one
point oh wow because that's a permanent
choice that would have been a permanent
choice and they did talk me out of it
because they were like do you want to
have kids one day and i was like yeah
that'd be great can you not breastfeed
if you have tattoos no that's not it
they uh just so that your nipples will
get larger and then you'll have like a
ring tattoo around
so they were like maybe we should just
like table this just right now and you
can just keep giving yourself titty
twisters before you hook up with someone
oh my god that is the funniest [ __ ] i've
ever heard so hard
oh my that is the funniest thing i've
ever heard well our third on burden is
another uh social media faux pas and
it's pretty bad i'm not gonna lie oh no
hello shannon and claudia i have had
this eating away at me and i have yet to
tell my husband because i'm mortified
i woke up one morning and took a video
of my dog she sleeps at the foot of our
bed in a crate and i thought it would be
a cute cute thing to show what our
mornings look like to my dad
i sent the video to him not realizing my
husband was completely naked in the
background no i went back to watch the
video a few days later and i realized
what i did i can't say anything to my
dad because i was so mortified at what i
did and i haven't bothered telling my
husband because i knew he would just be
so embarrassed i can't believe i made
such a dumb [ __ ] mistake and i will
never take a video while in our bedroom
ever again clothed or not love you
yeah never tell your husband and pretend
like it never happened like let your dad
think that
you don't know
what you did so just let him think this
is like his secret to hold on to also
it's quite possible like dads are not
the most savvy it's very possible like
he has no idea or that he didn't you
know how like a video is small and then
when you click on it it gets bigger yeah
maybe you can open it and the small icon
which i feel like the dads are clicking
they're not like expanding a video so
true maybe that's the thing also your
dad either doesn't know or feels wildly
uncomfortable because my dad is just
like a savage and he would just text me
back immediately and say something like
absurd but we don't know her dad's
personality so we have we're just
guessing he doesn't want you to bring it
up either because he would have either
tried to make light of it make a joke or
he would have like just been like this
is highly inappropriate and just let him
oh my this is like so horrible like he
doesn't send the video to someone else
oh like check out not noticing
a dog
oh no the next time you're with him like
dad sorry i was like can you help me
with my phone just go in and delete it
so he doesn't like have the ability to
send it to anyone else yeah and don't
ever tell your husband there's no reason
to embarrass him like no he doesn't need
to know and also don't talk it talk
about it with your dad one because
that's awkward and too it's very
possible you're right like he doesn't
know yeah oh my god never tell your
husband though that's horrible you have
to be so careful these days that's so i
saw the funniest thing once a while ago
someone sent me like had
some girl like sent
um a picture of her engaged like she got
engaged and she sent it to a live photo
yes have you seen that too yeah it went
like viral
honestly it's good for her for those who
don't know this girl like was sending a
picture of her engagement ring she was
like obviously got engaged maybe on
vacation they're like back in the hotel
room she's sending a picture of her
hatred and it's a live photo so if you
press it it's like her finger moving and
then her man jumping on the bed with his
dick fully out so what he actually was
doing which is like such a [ __ ] dude
move and they love to do this he he was
she was showing her ring and then he was
sweet helicoptering his dick to the ring
he was like being funny i guess like
yeah yeah and she was like oh thank god
i didn't get that in the photo but it
was a live photo live photos are so
[ __ ] dangerous because they have
sound too oh they have sound and i
sometimes will send a live photo on
purpose because it'll be like the ocean
or whatever and like one time i was so
embarrassed because i had not hiked i
don't really hike i just like walked
upstairs to this like spot to get a
picture of the ocean and you could hear
me over the crashing waves going
and i was mortified i sent it to a boy
as well and i was just like that's
horrible that is horrible yeah okay
that's i'm also such a creepy sneaky
little sleuth that like i knew that this
one guy that i was talking to that um i
don't talk to him i had to kill him in
my head he's the worst exactly and um
but he would i think he did not realize
he was sending live photos and i was
always like because they have sound good
don't let him i was like never going to
tell him that he was sitting live photos
because i was like what am i doing of
course the stalking is immaculate yes i
agree but in the future like if you're
sending photos just like always remember
about the live photo of it all because
it's really life photos are great like
when my sister sends me pictures of her
daughter like it's the best because like
i hear her like a little voice and she's
like running love but like in any other
circumstance they're horrifying so scary
and like the sound is just something
that you always forget about the sound
is so attached oh the sound yes it's
just it's so layered don't send live
photos so um thank you to everyone who
unburdened themselves if they ever want
to write in to us to unburden yourself
with something it's unburden yourself no
what is it unburden yourselves
gmail.com shannon thank you so much for
finally being here i adore you the
toasters adore you you're a queen tell
everyone where they can follow you where
to listen to your podcast yes etc um my
podcast is probably a podcast my
instagram is probably shannon ford i
made this let's talk about the probably
sorry that's not an episode yet what's
with the probably wait i okay i'm so
sorry to keep doing this but i have to
unburden myself at one thing yeah i
wouldn't like how you literally like oh
i don't think i have anything i don't
have anything i went back and forth on
whether or not i should talk about this
on the toes yeah you'll probably have
absolutely no idea what i'm talking
about drama yes okay i do because that
was my first intro was like i didn't
watch very cavalry and then someone was
sending me your instagram stories like
years ago but i'm not entirely sure what
happened you had some beef with the with
toasters no okay so it wasn't well it
was toasters but i didn't know okay so
this is even funnier because like my
friends from back home and like everyone
in my friend group was like abort abort
like you do not want to [ __ ] with the
table and i was like whatever and i just
like when someone like when people come
with pitchforks i like come with like
bigger yeah i just like that's just what
was the drama so basically it was a
subgroup it wasn't y'all's facebook
group so that's the that's the whole
issue that i was that's the issue with
having facebook groups it's like
horrible like disgusting [ __ ] goes down
in facebook groups that are here they
use our name right and it's like
friends of mine are like what the [ __ ]
is this group can you delete it i'm like
no i think i do i'm not in this group i
don't run this room right but it's like
toasters who love shannon ford and
they'll start a group and then they'll
start saying horrible things and
threatening you no so it was like a it
was a group of forty thousand was a
subgroup i need to preface a subgroup
and it was 40 000 people though and it
was back when i was selling presets
and um listen i know you can like give
them to your friends and like you can
but it's a business
i'll do whatever i get
but they had this thread where they were
someone's like i love shannon's presets
can you share them here and again like i
said i'm not so crazy to be like it's
stolen digital property but if you give
it to your friends give it to some of
your friends do it for sure send it to
whoever but like it was a group of forty
thousand people and i was just like
pretty pissed about it because it was
worth it and i was like hey and i just
remember being like i obviously know
this is not the own like the owners of
the of the toast but i was like like
could y'all like tell this group to like
stop it
cut it out yeah and um
they came from my [ __ ] jugular oh
yeah and i was like not prepared they
were like it was like oh you want to
take your presets down you're ugly as
[ __ ] and i was like what
i was like oh my god those facebook
groups were so tired
they were so toxic but i got a dm from
either you or jackie someone that like
literally just responded and was like
this is not us and i was like and that
was like so embarrassing they were
making us look so bad like acting like
fools it's by the way it's a full crime
like to just interview stolen digital
property like that's like someone you
know like ripping our audio from our
patreon and giving it away for free when
you get it when you like get the preset
you do like sign of course no it's fully
illegal so anyways all i know is that i
just like popped off for a second and i
was like listen you little [ __ ]
toaster strudels i was like i don't mean
who messaged you oh yeah well no it's
from the morning toast oh okay wait let
me i'm gonna go find it oh yeah so maybe
you'll be able to see but it was um yeah
it'll definitely be right up top um and
i was like listening to your little
[ __ ] toaster strudels we're not doing
this and i'm not scared of y'all and
everyone i mean i want to say five
minutes later i was issuing public
apologies literally i found it
you mentioned us in your story five
times and we wrote that's not our group
you're like oh i thought for sure it was
well the owner of that group or whatever
it is deleted the dropbox files anyway
so justice has been served sorry for
tagging you guys
that
sorry
literally 2019 two years later shannon
ford coming on the toes here we are full
circle someone did comment though when
you announced the thing someone was like
please bring up the og trump oh my god
i'm so glad you did because honestly i i
kind of remember there was drama but i
don't remember like what it was about
and by the way you're 100 justified like
thanks everyone to tell me though
immediately they were like abort mission
don't [ __ ] with the toasters and like
you should probably apologize for
calling them toaster strudels which i do
but it is it is an elite breakfast item
i like it by the way i don't think my
father the inventor of toasters
you i'm so glad we brought that up but
my initial question was why probably um
so it's really i just had to lean in
because i did it in college so
twitter twitter was huge and there was
no such thing as blue check marks right
so all of these celebrities names on
twitter were the real legit the real
claudio whatever so i thought i was just
like so funny it is funny now that you
explained it and i made mine probably
shane important honestly it did get
quite a few laughs um i think it's cute
and i kept it and then i went on the
show then i moved to nashville after
college and everyone kind of like i just
love attention and like people thought
it was funny and you're like oh i get it
that's funny and then i was on the show
and i really probably i tried to i i
emailed the girl or i dm the girl on
instagram whose name is shannon right
her bio literally says she works for
facebook so i tried to buy it from her
and she was like no and i was like oh um
and what about shannon ford is that
taken taken yeah and no hers is shannon
ford and justin
there's two people right shannon and
shannon ford at shannon would be cool
yeah it would just be cool i love people
that just have like i'm like what
ballers i know i one time tried to reach
out to the girl who has claudia and
she's never like no yeah exactly there's
so much power there is there just is so
many ways i i was on the show and then
my brand started like doing all things
and then i just honestly there's a lot
of like funny things you can do with it
like probably a podcast i didn't have to
think twice whenever i was in my podcast
right it's a great name for a podcast
and then like merch like my actually the
guy that does my merch he got me this
for christmas it's like what does it say
probably love but it's funny because
dudes at bars will be like you can tell
they forgot my name probably and they
like glance down and then they're like
[ __ ] that's not right
hey probably yeah you wanna
yeah they're like that's not your name
so anyways yeah that's that's where
probably started and i really just had
to lean the [ __ ] into it so glad we just
wrapped that up before because i had so
many questions and they've been answered
there you go shannon thank you so much
for being here your first time on the
morning toast was a hit success i hope
you will join us again i will would love
to pleasure um and that's our show you
guys tomorrow we are back in studio with
paige desorbo and then thursday
love unreal thursday jackie's back um
remote so we'll have a nice catch up
with jackie on thursday and then i'm
headed to chicago on friday there are 30
well last time i checked 30 seats left
at the chicago theater which is so crazy
i do believe they consider that a
sellout but i'd really like to sell the
extra 30 so
girls no job.com tour then kansas city
on sunday hope everyone has an amazing
day don't forget to follow shannon on
instagram listen to her podcast she's a
queen we love you guys have an amazing
day and we'll see you tomorrow bye bye
you